[Music]  as we've been reporting businesses  nationwide struggling to find  employees the lack of workers even being  felt at pools  was a lifeguard shortage but help may be  on the way as certifications for  lifeguard training have increased across  the nation and pay raises  are the reason why many are diving into  the gig they're happening here in las  vegas and all the way to new york  it's going up from 17 to 25 and  we just actually posted about a job 30  in the hamptons  a day camp like hello modified that is  the hamptons all right massachusetts is  also offering state lifeguards a 500  bonus in texas wages for lifeguards are  up 30 percent  here in las vegas we contacted the city  and found out pay for lifeguards  increased in june by two dollars an hour  due to a lack of lifeguards  so with the raise right now the city  offers lifeguards 13 bucks an hour  water safety instructors 15 bucks hourly  and pool manager 17 dollars an hour